[Music]
hi it's Michele from lab muffin BB
science chemistry PhD skincare nerd and
pimple magnet acne patches what are they
and how do they work that's the topic of
today's video we're talking about all
the different types of stickers that you
can stick on your face when you're
having a breakout if you like this sort
of video give it a thumbs up subscribe
to my channel and click the notification
bell so you don't miss any of my videos
there are three main types of acne
patches as of now I'm sure they'll embed
more soon they are hydrocolloid patches
acne treatment patches and microneedle
patches all three of them will help
protect your pimples from rubbing and
scratching and keep them clean sometimes
if you have a pimple you'll
subconsciously peek at it even in your
sleep and it protects it from things
like rubbing on your pillowcase or on
your hair they also help keep an open
blowing noise for faster and better
healing depending on the type of patch
they can also help deliver active
ingredients to your pimple or help
active ingredients absorb better they
can also absorb and draw out any fluid
that's losing out from your pimple
pimple patches also help protect your
pimples from UV light this is good
because then it reduces the amount of
post inflammatory hyperpigmentation that
can develop these are brown patches on
your skin of pigment that develop after
you've had acne and these can take ages
and ages to fade I have a video all
about how to fade these patches but it's
always best to try to reduce how much
forms in the first place pimple patches
are also usually waterproof so it means
that you don't have to reapply them
every time you wash your face unless you
wash it a bit too hard and what it gets
under the bandage let's talk about the
specifics of each of these three types
let's start with hydrocolloid bandages
hydrocolloid bandages were originally
used for ulcers but they became popular
for treating acne and Asia they're
getting a lot easy to find outside of
Asia as well these bandages are flexible
and they're made of the water attracting
material on a thin plastic membrane
there's adhesive on the other side of
the water attracting material so you
stick it onto your skin with the water
attracting material facing down the
tough plastic outer film is usually made
of polyurethane and this helps keep
everything in place it's also waterproof
so stops water from evaporating from
your wound and keeps them moist this
helps it heal faster and the new skin
that forms is more supple and flexible
so it doesn't feel tight and stretched
out the plastic film also protects the
wound against
scratching and it helps stop the water
attracting material from absorbing water
from the atmosphere you wanted to mostly
absorb water from your wound the water
attracting material is usually made of
carboxymethyl cellulose pectin or
gelatin or a combination of these these
materials are really good at attracting
and holding onto water and so it helps
draw fluid out of your pimple they're
basically just humectant moisturizers
strung together into a giant solid chunk
of humectant as fluid goes into the
bandage it turns into an opaque white
color and so you get this very
satisfying white spot what's good about
the hydrocolloid bandages
there are actually quite a few studies
on the benefits of hydrocolloid bandages
on open wounds but there's only one on
acne they found out putting 3m acne
dressings on pimples changing them every
two days reduce the severity of acne it
also reduced redness oiliness and dark
pigmentation and this was compared with
skin tapes sort of like the paper tape
that i used to measure up the size of my
face the downside of hydrocolloid
bandages is that they're a little bit
pricier than other acne treatment
patches they also tend to be thicker
than acne patches and this gets even
thicker when they absorb more liquid a
few tips for using hydrocolloid bandages
you can buy bigger bandages which are
intended for use on wounds and cut them
up into smaller shapes you can use
scissors or you can use their hole punch
there are thinner Hydra color bandages
that you can buy that tend to stick on
and stay on a bit better they also blend
in a bit better if you want to wear them
out during the day when you're buying
hydrocolloid bandages be really careful
they look almost the same as acne
treatment patches so make sure it
actually says hydrocolloid on the
package I've heard some people say that
hydrocolloid bandages work fine on
intact pimples for them personally for
me I found that it works better if I've
lanced the pimple first so I've poked a
little hole in it you can see some tips
on how to safely squeeze a pimple in
another video that I've done I've linked
it in the description the second type of
acne patch is the acne treatment patch
these contain active ingredients that
are delivered to the pimple while it's
on the most common active ingredients in
these are salicylic acid and tea tree
oil which are both great for pimples
these look a lot like hydrocolloid
bandages basically they're like the
hydrocolloid bandage - that
hydrocolloids layer plus the acne
ingredients
they usually end up being a lot cheaper
as well the benefits of these acne
treatment patches because they're
including the skin they help your skin
absorb ingredients better than if it's
open to the air the patch also keeps the
active ingredients right on the spot
where your pimple is so it doesn't get
rubbed off or moved around on your skin
like with the other patches that helps
protect your pimple from rubbing and
scratching it also keeps your pimple
moist so that it heals faster plus it
keeps it clean the disadvantage of acne
treatment patches is that if you haven't
kept the area clean or if you're
sensitive to any of the active
ingredients in the patch then your
reaction will be amplified because of
that occlusive covering one time I
stupidly use one on a pimple right
before a wedding and overnight the
pimple became three times its size so
the moral of the story there is try the
patch before it's an important event a
few tips for using acne treatment
patches make sure your skin is clean
underneath the patch before you put it
on it will stick on better Plus will
reduce the chance of you sealing
something irritating onto your skin even
though the active ingredients in the
patches are usually quite similar they
still perform quite differently so make
sure you've read some reviews before you
try buying some when you're buying it
again they look a lot like hydrocolloid
patches so make sure you check which one
you're buying acne treatment patches
will usually have the active ingredients
somewhere in the description plus
they'll be a fair bit cheaper than
hydrocolloid bandages finally dissolving
microneedle patches these are the newest
fanciest ones on the market these are
sticky bandages that have a water
soluble chip on top this chip has lots
of little micro needles on it think of
it like a specially shaped chip of sugar
that's embedded with active ingredients
again the active ingredients in these
are things that you usually find in acne
spot treatments so things like salicylic
acid niacin amide antioxidants and
hyaluronic acid in some of these the
sticky bandage is also a hydrocolloid
banished to the key idea with these is
that the micro needles can get beyond
the skin barrier the stratum corneum
this top layer of skin that acts as a
really good barrier to any active
ingredients that you put on the micro
needles get past this so that the active
ingredients can get to the pimple where
they're needed this is what the micro
needles look like up close
please excuse my shaky camera work it is
a microscopes that every time I wiggled
it shows up like a giant wiggle the
shape and length of the micro needles
depends on the specific brand and
product that you're using some needles
are round some are square some are even
cross shaped it takes about two hours
for the micro needles to dissolve in the
water that's naturally already present
in your skin these micro needles might
look really pointy and scary but these
are massively zoomed in you can see
relative to my finger they're really
tiny and they don't go in very deep at
all you might have seen people use derma
rollers and there's lots of blood and
pain involved but the micro needles in
these patches are a lot shorter and so
they don't reach deep enough to draw out
any blood or cause any pain in terms of
comfort usually it doesn't really feel
like much it feels a little bit stiff
and rough until you get used to it and I
think mostly that's just because you've
got this hardship stuck to your skin the
biggest advantage of these micro needle
patches is that they can get through the
stratum corneum and so they deliver
active ingredients a lot more
efficiently active ingredients also
lasts a lot longer in microneedle
patches than in say or water-based serum
and so things like antioxidants are more
likely to still be active when you apply
it the biggest disadvantage of these is
that they tend to be really expensive
and that's because there's just a lot
that goes into making these there's also
a lot of packaging involved with these
because the micro needles are quite
fragile they need to be protected from
getting bumped against before you put it
on your skin they also need to be
protected against moisture in the air
because then they'll just start
dissolving and so usually if they're
packaged individually or in small
packets with some sort of water
absorbing desiccant a few chips were
using these again make sure your skin is
clean before you put them on and make
sure it's also dry so that the micro
needles can actually get through your
skin before they start dissolving it's
recommended that you use these at the
very first sign of a pimple I personally
found these most of them
davonne medium depth pimples not the
really really deep cystic pimples that
you sometimes get under the skin usually
it's with pimples that come to a head
after a few days when I use these I can
actually see the people stopped growing
after a few hours and it works even
better overnight which one I prefer
really depends on the type of pimple I
have this might be completely different
for you this is just from my personal
experience if I have a pimple that's got
lots of fluid or pus then I go for the
hydrocolloid bandage because it's
capable of absorbing all the fluid
without just sliding off if I have a
really nasty medium depth pimple then I
go straight for the microneedle patches
I usually save these for the nastier
pimples because they are a bit more
expensive so I try to be a bit more
sparing when I use them I haven't had
great luck with acne patches but I know
other people have I would personally use
them on slightly smaller less inflamed
pimples that I feel like don't really
deserve a microneedle patch I think the
most important thing when you're using
these is to make sure you clean your
skin really well before you apply it on
I've listed a few brands of acne patches
that I've tried in the caption I haven't
tried a ton of them so please leave me a
comment if you have any recommendations
if you have really strong feelings about
a particular product I hope you enjoyed
this video if you did it would be great
if you liked the video and subscribe to
my channel you can also follow me on
instagram at lab muffin beauty science
and you can check out my blog for lots
and lots of content on beauty science
see you next time